his name's Godspeed and he's from the
future
welcome back everyone is Charlie the
flash is back this is going to be my season
6 episode 1 video we have so many Easter
eggs to talk about it's crisis on
Infinite Earths
every single episode this season the
first half will deal with crisis stuff
we're doing a weekly flash ring giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your best theory
about crisis on Infinite Earths in the
video careful for spoilers if you have
not seen the episode yet so here we go
top 10 and easter eggs number 10 the
mystery opening glitch in the Time Vault
we found out at the end of the episode
the monitor was responsible for this
he's like yeah I totally did it on
purpose but if you noticed during the
episode there were several moments where
they basically tried to clear a lot of
what's going on in that previous future
nor a timeline because the timeline was
wiped
even though Nora's technology survived
because it was designed to be impervious
to timeline changes that coupled with
the very first villain which I'll talk
about in a second because it was a very
big villain twist is all about them
introducing the new version of the
timeline that will play out in Easter
eggs over the rest of the season we
might not learn everything about the new
future timeline that Nora will come from
and her potential twin brother from the
comics the tornado twins until next
season but the showrunner said there
would be a lot of Easter eggs for that
so we'll just pick him out episode by
episode as we see him number 9 though
probably one of the biggest the
Godspeed army that's slowly been forming
over the last four months so they do
that big-time jump four months later
after the end of last season it was a
great opening action scene they remind
you about a bunch of details from
godspeed last season that he's a
velocity-9 speedster in the world of the
flash they name drop August heart but
the big surprises is that it's just
another mechanical automaton something
that someone in the future is sending
back into the past and it's the fourth
one in as many months so they have four
different versions of godspeed locked up
in iron Heights just think about that
it's a small Godspeed army that's slowly
forming what's gonna happen if all those
versions of Godspeed escape at the same
time that seems like it's gonna blow up
in their face maybe later this season
but the whole idea is is that there's a
villain from the potential future with
the technology to create artificial god
speeds so it has to be someone that's
either really smart or from a very
distant version of the future there are
only a couple of flash films we know
that come from that far in the future in
abracadabra is one of the few ones we
haven't
a long time also this probably has
something to do with the villain from
the second half of the season remember
even though they introduced the blood
work villain during this episode he's
only here for the first half of the
season there'll be a different bill in
the back cap and everyone obviously is
thinking might be Red but he's
just one of the other picks of potential
villains from the future because the
last time we heard about Red on
the flash was when we were in that noir
episode in the future timeline at the
flash Museum and they were mentioning
him and passing as one of the greatest
foes of the flash so just remember big
godspeed mystery coming from the future
but it's not a gas heart it's just a
bunch of artificial versions of godspeed
at this point number 8 catching up with
team flash this is where they set up the
SU didney arc for Ralph didney he's been
traveling all over the world because of
the file he was looking at at the end of
last season it's soo didney from the
comics they're gonna introduce her later
this season they've already confirmed it
they didn't say which episode is gonna
happen so it could be the first half of
the season or the second half of the
season but obviously you know they get
married her name is sue Dearborn because
that's her maiden name
iris is still running the central city
citizen things are going well with that
they catch up with team flash Cisco is
building a version of cerebro using the
Speed Force that will allow Barry to
basically see potential time lines using
the Speed Force the same way that dr.
strange used the time stone during
Avengers infinity war there were
actually a lot of Marvel references and
easter eggs during this episode but
they're calling it the mental
augmentation chamber and Barry sounds
like he wants to use it like Minority
Report to catch crimes before they
happen because he's using potential
alternate futures to find criminals
before they actually commit the act
spoiler warning for Minority Report that
never goes well so no matter what's
gonna happen with this device things
were gonna go completely off the rails
number 6 meet the new blood work villain
Ramsey Rosa that's his name in the
comics they changed a couple things
about his backstory they say he's one of
Caitlin's friends from medical school
and his mother who died who the funeral
was for at the beginning of the episode
is the person who got Caitlin the job at
STAR Labs in the first place this is
them giving him a lot of history and
ties to her character but you learn that
he just wants dark matter because he's
created a cure for cancer that requires
it and it might maybe turn people into
metahumans which it then totally does at
the end of the episode if you're not
familiar with the blood work villain he
actually appeared during the negative
flash
are we actually got a look on set of a
future episode I think it's episode 7 or
episode 8 where we see what looks like
Barry turning into a negative flash so
we might actually get some of that this
season number 5 they're a whole bunch of
Marvel Easter eggs when they're at the
junkyard
well first iris calls Cisco Ghostbusters
because of the device he's using to scan
for dark matter cisco talks about gamma
rays magnetar fields gamma rays
obviously talking about the Hulk there
was also a killer frost Caitlin Hulk's
style storyline in a bit of a riff on
their storyline during Avengers infinity
war with the Hulk kind of fighting
Banner within his mind for control of
the body
dude you're embarrassing me from the
Wizards we get the quick reminder that
Joe West is the new police chief captain
Singh I guess has gone on to greener
pastures but maybe he'll still appear on
the show every once in a while but
number 4 we meet Chester P trunk from
the comics he is a flash comic book
villain his ability was opening
wormholes to other realities but when
they show him on screen there are a
whole bunch of meta Easter eggs for Star
Wars and even more Marvel Easter eggs if
you look at some of the chat names I'm
probably missing a couple of them here
but there's wookie lover 77 for Star
Wars released in 1977 Pizza Parker is a
reference to Tobey Maguire's version of
spider-man from spider-man to pizza time
but they find the Chester P trunk has
been connected to the black holes
somehow he's been given this ability
that allows him to create black holes we
kind of learned it's a little more
complicated than that during the final
big action see because berry literally
flies through a black hole and it takes
him to another part of space but that's
basically what his comic book powers are
and even though at the end of the
episode they're able to reconnect his
consciousness to his body his eyes are
glowing all yellow that just means that
he'll probably be able to continue
opening portals across the multiverse
later in the season when Cisco is
talking about solutions and creates that
stellar grenade there's a really deep
cut mission impossible Emilio Estevez
referenced when he says hasta lasagna
don't get any Anya elongated man gives
us a nice Super Man reference there's
gonna be so many versions of Superman
coming during crisis on Infinite Earths
snow tryst of Solitude the whole killer
frost thing is basically her just being
pissed off the Caitlin only uses her for
fighting then they work it out and she
agrees to let killer frost be the
dominant personality this season so it
just means way more killer frost in
episodes than Caitlyn as you've seen
before normally it's just a little bit
of killer frost in mostly Caitlyn now
it's gonna be the other way around for
season six
just like the Flash's new costume is way
better than last year's costume her
costume is also way better than the
previous versions of her costumes but
number three the big Flash Gordon scene
I was so surprised in laughing so hard I
was so happy with the way they used this
cisco says I've been saving this one for
a long time they play the theme song
from Flash Gordon Asbury flies into the
wormhole or the black hole just like
Flash Gordon did in his movie the brand
new ability that he's using we've never
actually seen him do before is creating
a bubble of Speed Force protection
around himself Cisco refers to it as a
Speed Force aura to protect himself from
the gravimetric forces but he carries
the consciousness of Chester P trunk
puts it back in his body inside their
special cerebro device then basically
say that he's gonna have to bake in
there for three to four weeks with his
code for three to four episodes that's
just them saying that they probably
won't be able to use that special device
for anything good for a couple more
weeks but number two blood work gets his
comic book powers so he naturally uses
the dark matter from the gun that he
acquired in the black market to test his
cure for cancer on himself it totally
works but then as caitlin foretold it
could turn people into metahumans it's
straight up turns him into comic book
blood work the way they visualize his
powers is similar to the way his powers
work in the comics but they tune down
the bright red and now it's a little
more real-world if you didn't read that
flash rebirth or ik he just has the
ability to control blood he can create
constructs he can control the blood in
other people including the flash so he
can actually partially control the flash
by controlling his blood that might have
something to do with the negative flash
stuff that we've seen from them on set
but while Barry was on the other side of
space through that black hole he grabbed
Nora's jacket which had been sucked in
and they put it in the place where they
used to keep reverse flashes costume
inside the Time Vault reverse flash is a
big part of crisis on Infinite Earths
just like he said last season he will be
back I'll see you at the next crisis
our next crisis
then big number one the end credits
scene crisis on Infinite Earths the
monitor rolls in and explains why he
destroyed Nora's device because I don't
want you to have hope because in order
for billions to survive the flash must
die so it's basically him giving him a
comic book spoiler for crisis on
Infinite Earths in no surprise episode 2
next week is called a flash of the
lightning that's the name of the issue
where flash died during crisis on
Infinite Earths so that's why next week
Barry is gonna travel to the future to
try and get a glimpse and see what
really happens and then he goes to Jay
Garrick for help so next week big Jay
Garrick episode but he did put an actual
date on the Flash's now I think we
all believe that Oliver Queen is gonna
sacrifice himself that's the whole point
of this is that he's going to do
something different so that Barry does
not disappear during crisis but the
actual day is December 10th 2019 that's
just gonna be the day of the flash
episode of the crossover see how they
did that this is the full schedule for
all the episodes of the crossover first
three airing in December then they go on
break then come back in January you get
the second part of the crossover then
whatever explosive conclusion so they
really are gonna kill off Oliver Queen
that might not wind up happening till
the January episodes but everybody post
your favorite moments from the episode
in the comments if you have any big
questions or there are any Easter eggs
you spotted that I didn't mention in the
video I feel like it was a great first
episode way better than season 5 way
better than season 4 there is a brand
new showrunner who's actually working on
the show so he did a great job of
setting a whole bunch of stuff up for
future episodes and for the back half of
the season like I said I think the God
speed stuff might be connected to the
back half of the season what will happen
is is I'll do a trailer video for
episode 2 and post that tomorrow I named
a giveaway winner when I do that while
you wait for everything click here for
all my flash crisis on infinite or
trailer videos and learn about what's
going on with all the Superman and click
here for all my Joker movie videos
Easter eggs the ending scene and my
review video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight